ciao a tutti allora questo video vorrei
dedicarlo a tutti quelli che amano
andare in palestra a voi amanti del
fitness vorrei fare una domanda ma
perchè vi odiate ma cosa avete fatto di
male nella vita per punire poi così
tanto ma questo punto nera dico meglio
il cilicio palestra anagrammato e
strappa le e potrei chiuderlo quel video
testa seguiti può farti sentire la
carbonara dei feci però so se ci avete
fatto caso ma in palestra non esistono
vie di mezzo o ci sono tipo questi
flaccidi abomini della tiroide che non
sanno tali attrezzi una volta capiscono
che stava usando una pressa per le gambe
con le braccia tipo macchina per
affettare i salumi oppure ci sono tipo
questi tizi super definiti che sembrano
delle radiografie
ecco la domanda è perché queste specie
convivono nello stesso luogo perché tipo
a nessuno può essere ancora venuto in
mente di fare una sezione impenetrabile
tipo kgb per tutte quelle persone che
ancora ci stanno provando a perde peso
quindi che ne so piena di clet viru lan
attrezzi è un'altra sezione per tutti
quelli che invece sono già in mega forma
pazzeschi piena di specchi ma perché le
guardate i muscoli cazzo fanno non lo so
allenano alla vista e cioè che se non di
fissate il visibile per due secondi
questo scappa tranquilli stalli io odio
dove sentire i versi delle persone
quando sollevano i pesi che sembra che
stia avvenendo un esorcismo
uno schifo la virgin secondo me la
chiamano così perché sacrificano le
vergini assalto quindi immagino questi
qua che mettesse stanno lì tutti quanti
erano con le vene che gli escono al
collo a sollevare sti bilanciati da 10
mila tonnellate a un certo punto dalle
mutandine parte così buca ed emorroidi
tipo spose che disagio infinito come le
ragazze si truccano per andare in
palestra ma che problemi a volte vedo
queste qua tutte quante intero che
arrivano in palestra che sembra un carro
dei draq queen
ride o certe robe in faccia che
cliomakeup che toglierebbe l'amicizia
ora ma non l'avete capito che tanto a
fine giornata vi trovate a faccia per
terra per quanto sudato ma è mai mosso
scivola sul vostro contouring io col
sudore voi hanno dei seri problemi
ragazzi non possiamo lasciare le scimmie
come le lumache ma appena entrano in
palestra questa iniziato a sudare ma che
so hansel e gretel che devono ritrovare
uscita il mio forte rischio di rimanere
incollato agli attrezzi ma che ci avete
frari chiappe bostik avrete un business
poi in palestra circolano certe ascelle
da porto d'armi che ok che in palestra
si suda si aprirà un posto sollevare
pesi al ritmo dei conati nel mio vomito
o vogliamo parlare dei vecchi quelli che
hanno l'attaccatura dei capelli qua
sulla nuca che occupano gli attrezzi
così seduti come se fossero lo so
dall'estetista fas e il freccia le dita
dei piedi
nel frattempo che disti bacucchi con
riporto che ci provano con le minorenni
anzi io non te la da adesso è disperata
ma se d'arresto siamo anche se provi con
una ragazzina e sia perché c'è un
sognatore eccessivo e se un ottimista
cronico e poi sono gli stessi che
spogliatoio tipo si urlano da una parte
all'altra me hanno sventrato la tipa di
turno con loro mini pene roba che
secondo me gli hanno fatto una puntura
l'avete vaccinate io non so perché ma
negli spogliatoi
le persone si trasfigurano ci sono
queste cose appena entrano si spogliano
e camminano di costi batacchi che a
volte quando te camminano troppo vicine
ci schiaffeggiano pure ci stanno quelli
che stanno nodi e te parano davanti a te
tu stai seduto e ti stanno due
centimetri in piedi ma che volete che
faccia un buon non ha mai visto invece
quelli che si asciugano il pen in
modalità stereo co2 phon e cercano dico
di sfidare la gravità tutta potenza può
un uomo palloncino delle fiere e tu lo
vedi racket e salute passaggi perché
fanno crucis ed ecco è per colpa di
quelli come voi che ho smesso di
sorridere mattina quello spogliatoio noi
ti spogliato della fede nel messia
restano insegnato una cosa che la vita
in meno
snake e dietetici alle macchinette roba
che io dopo due ore the fall è stato
lancia un fronte parroco è pronto e
quelli soli nella vita che vengono in
palestra per attaccarti i due pipponi
mentre stai correndo sul tapis roulant
io sto già con la pompa dell'ossigeno
attaccato malato terminale eto'o viene
da me a parlarmi dei cazzi tuoi perché
ha bisogno d'affetto e volete risponde
ma sta per calciare amici perché con
questo metodo gli estesi tu poi lippi
che se fanno i self idamante ogni
specchio della palestra a voi vi devono
hackerati l'animale devono toglie il
battesimo in quattro anni senza
scherzare se ero andato in palestra
otto volte due volte l'anno una dopo due
pale e 1 dopo pasqua roba che chissà
quanti soldi avrò perso anzi chissà con
quei soldi quanto cibo aver potuto
comprarci e facciano ho trovato ne vado
a dizzy scrive ciao
[Musica]